more than two years after schools shut
down at the beginning of the pandemic
students are still missing class and
tonight ccsd leaders talking about ways
to get them back on track sasha loftis
was at tonight's board meeting spoke
with parents who say their kids have
really fallen behind yes brian and
denise we know this has been a major
issue these past few years i spoke with
one parent who says her son really has
suffered and she wants to see more done
to help kids like him my son has been
part of that that number diana batista
shares the struggles her son has faced
since the kovid 19 pandemic he missed
almost the entire school year because of
the in-access issues that he had she
says the fifth grader who has special
needs was unenrolled by the district and
has had to work hard to catch up what
harm has been done to them and what did
they miss batista was one who stood up
to speak out on this during the ccsd
board of trustees latest discussion to
combat chronic absenteeism in the
chronic absenteeism rate last school
year 39 percent of students missed at
least 10 percent of their enrolled days
about 22 percent higher than the
district's target rate we were so proud
of our educators who were going out and
teams and really putting forth that
extra effort the plan put forth renewing
the truancy prevention outreach program
which involves identifying at risk kids
root causes for missing class and
reaching out to families their issue is
at home and not necessarily just even a
stable living environment leaders hope
it will make a difference while batista
encourages parents to always look out
for their kids this is the reality of a
lot of what we all have to think about
on a daily basis
when it comes to race black students
missed the most school last year with a
50 percent absenteeism rate followed by
hawaiian and pacific islander students
than hispanic or latino students we have
a look at the facts and figures on our
website right now 8newsnow.com